thank you
all right President Biden was still here
in New York City on a great crowd today
and for more meetings with world leaders
uh boy I wonder what impression they
walked away with and of course more
fundraisers but things did not go
particularly well for Joey your
president take a look
to say to president can you hear me
President Biden
this is an historical moment for Brazil
and for the U.S President Biden can you
hear me
you can yes good I know I'm not supposed
to speak again but my dad used to have
an expression
when I was growing up my father had an
expression
my father was uh did not have a college
degree but he was a well-read man he
worked very hard his whole life you say
Joe
a job is about a lot more than a
paycheck
it's about your dignity
it's about self-respect
does that include Hunter's job I'm just
asking and despite Biden's constant
struggles and his mumbling and bumbling
and very low poll numbers his team is
now telling worry Democrats to relax
because apparently they believe that by
focusing on Donald Trump and abortion
they're going to be able to win easily
next year excuse me anyway joining us
now live in studio 2024 presidential
candidate Vivek Rama Swami
thank you
man how are you good to see you good to
see you
I've noticed as time has gotten on
you've come under more fire what do you
think that is well look I think that
it's politics yeah at the start of this
race that was at 0.0 in the polls nobody
cared about me in the race now we're
verging on second and third in most
national polls and you're going to run
for U.S president if you can't handle
the heat you stay out of the kitchen so
I can handle the heat and it my view
Sean is we talk to all media left-wing
media right wing media no Wing media if
I'm not willing to sit across the table
from the people who disagree with me
then I'm not willing to sit ready to sit
across table sit next to the jackasses
of fake news CNN or msdnc don't you feel
like you're wasting your time by the way
not many people are watching fake news
CNN you know the fact of the matter is
there are times when I feel that way but
I'm not running to lead a political
party Sean
you want to be watched well you know
what I think that my view is we have to
talk to the people who disagree with us
because every time we do it we show up
and we win you'll remember with Don
Lemon that last interview that he did
with me was one of his last ones before
he got kicked off the air so we're doing
Services through this campaign
our time said yeah
it's very complicated to be a
conservative I think we believe in
limited government lower taxes more for
individual Freedom amen you know look at
the things we want we want secure
borders we want Law and Order Safety and
Security yes we want energy Independence
we want constitutionalists on the bench
we believe in peace through strength
um and and then leave us the hell alone
that's about right not that hard and you
know what Sean here's the real thing in
the country that's not even a Republican
versus Democrat idea those are basic
American ideals I think 80 percent of
this country agrees on the ideals that
you just listed the American dream the
idea that you get ahead in this country
not on the color of your skin but on the
content of your character I think eighty
percent of people in this country agree
on that and half the 20 are people
younger than me who never learned those
ideals in the first place we're going to
bring them along too and if we do Sean I
think we can win the 2024 election in a
landslide with a multi-ethnic
working-class coalition leave no State
Left Behind no City left behind I think
that's the opportunity with this failing
president from the economy to the
poorest border this is our opportunity
if we have the courage to actually stand
up for our own Vision that's how we win
deep and profound the Republican party
has to be the party of working men and
women yes I believe that it also has to
be the party that brings minorities on
board yes that have been lied to and
frankly disappointed regularly by the
Democratic party they have been failed
the schools are failing uh no doubt
about it I'll tell you an inspiring safe
and secure Sean so I've gone to places
like the south side of Chicago or
Kensington in the in the city of
Philadelphia you didn't get shot in this
campaign well I mean I've been to third
world countries growing up you go to the
third world you want to where you go go
to Kensington in Philadelphia today but
here's what I saw on the south side of
Chicago 90 black room supposedly mostly
Democrat that is a room that fully
agreed with me on Military Rising the
southern border on ending that border
crisis that is impacting their Community
every bit as much as Republican
communities across this country and so
America First includes all Americans
that's what I say I agree Americans
should not be suffering under Biden's
economy his idiotic energy plans we
shouldn't have open borders you know we
need Law and Order these are the basics
these are all those all preventable
problems that he caused why do you think
he chose that path well look I want to
say something about Biden and why I
don't talk about him that much on the
campaign Trail I don't even think he's
really the one running the country Sean
I think he is a puppet for the
managerial class in the administrative
State and you mark my words when I'm the
nominee they're not going to let him run
against me it's going to be the next
puppet that they Trot out so we have to
recognize that this is a broken system
we have to stand up to that managerial
class shut down those three letter
agencies it's not by that's alone the
problem it's the three letter agencies
and the Deep State we have to get in
there and shut it down but the upper
echelon tend to control everything the
managerial class and so yes there's 25
percent of people in those agencies who
are doing important work but I think
that we have to downsize the government
significantly 75 head count reduction
that's what I'm bringing to Washington
D.C there you go back hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else